that's anhace's car flying down the
street minutes before crashing into a
home and starting a fire it all unfolded
friday in the los angeles neighborhood
of mar vista the actress ending up in
the hospital in critical condition this
video showing the woman on a stretcher
flailing and according to neighbors
screaming at the time a rep for the
53-year-old actress tells e.t she's
since been upgraded to stable condition
but did suffer burns in the crash
adding quote her family and friends
asked for your thoughts and prayers and
to respect her privacy during this
difficult time
the accident remains under investigation
according to tmz just before that
incident ann drove her vehicle into a
garage door of a nearby apartment
building
witnesses of that accident captured a
photo of the star in her car with what
appeared to be a bottle of alcohol in
her cup holder before she sped away and
smashed into the house
inside the house at the time the woman
who was renting the home her next door
neighbor explained what she told him
she was in the house at the time
and the car stopped like two feet away
from where she was sitting so she was
pretty lucky in a video captured by cbs
los angeles you can see the damage left
behind after ann crashed your car into
the garage of that home according to
authorities it took 59 firefighters more
than an hour to put out the flames but
anne is the only person believed to be
injured in the ordeal
two of anne's exes actors thomas jane
and james tupper spoke out following the
terrifying accident thomas who worked
with ann on the hbo show hung
said she is quote expected to pull
through
and james who shares 12 year old son
atlas with anne captioned this throwback
pick of the two with quote thoughts and
prayers for this lovely woman actress
and mother tonight anne heish we love
you
[Music]
back in 2020 anne competed on dancing
with the stars where she reflected on
her challenges in hollywood saying the
industry shunned her for having a
same-sex relationship with ellen
degeneres we went through an incredible
time and we were part of a truly a part
of a revolution that helped move the
needle but when she stopped by the e.t
set soon after she reflected on the good
that came out of that experience too
i'm so thrilled to have been by her side
what i was talking about was a little
bit more of a concept that love is a
choice
and i made one and it was one of the
most life-changing choices of of my life
and i stand up for that more than i
would i would do the same thing all over
again this is a this is a time and
opportunity for me to be able to say
that i believe love is a choice and and
we all should support everyone's to have
their own private life and do what they
want to do if they're experiencing a
little bit of joy with another person
[Music]